cuál de las siguientes tablas describe
correctamente los puntos de la función
exponencial fx igual a 3 haga menos x
menos 2
vemos que cada tabla tiene los mismos
valores de xy sólo cambian los valores
de fx tomamos el primer valor x igual a
menos 2 y vamos a sustituirlo en esta
fórmula efe de menos 2
es igual a 3 elevado al menos xy como x
es menos 2 lo ponemos así
menos 2 esto es igual a 3 - por menos es
más 3 al cuadrado menos 2
3 x 39 menos 2 va a ser igual a 7 así
que para el valor de x menos 2 f x va a
ser igual a 7 veamos cuáles son nuestras
opciones menos 2 fx menos 18 esta no es
- 2 f x menos 4 tampoco es para menos 2
f x menos 18 novenos tampoco es y
efectivamente nada más nos queda esta
opción la d
que es nuestra opción correcta
eso estuvo bastante sencillo vamos a ver
el siguiente problema
a base 6 de 40 es igual a lo que aquí
nos piden es recordar cómo calcular un
logaritmo con una base arbitraria si
sólo tenemos en nuestra calculadora cómo
resolver algoritmos base 10 esto se
comprobó en un vídeo anterior pero la
idea general es que si yo tengo el
logaritmo
con base a deben
esto es lo mismo que decir que el
logaritmo
base 10 debe
entre el logaritmo
base 10 de a son iguales
y esto no necesariamente tiene que ser
el logaritmo base de 10 tiene que ser la
misma base tanto para el numerador como
el denominador eso es el único requisito
aunque pues normalmente el logaritmo
base 10 es conveniente porque todas las
calculadoras lo traen sustituyendo a y b
b es 40
6 pues será nuestro logaritmo
base 6 de 40 va a ser igual a logaritmo
base 10 de 6 / logaritmo
el logaritmo base 10 de 40 que es
nuestra opción d
este también fue un problema bastante
sencillo veremos el siguiente problema
cuando escribió la ecuación logaritmo
base 6 de x 4 igual a 0 en el pizarrón
necesita una pista para resolver el
problema cuál hecho le proporciona la
información que necesita para resolver
el problema de hecho no sé si es que él
necesita información este enunciado nos
dice que el 6 elevado a la 0 va a ser
igual a x a la menos 4 sumamos 4 en
ambos lados de la ecuación nos queda 6 a
las 04 igual a x
y yo creo que si juan no conoce esa
definición de que un número elevado a la
potencia cero es igual a uno lo va a
necesitar
si no conoce este enunciado lo va a
necesitar ya que 60 va a ser uno más 4
esto va a ser igual a x por lo tanto x
va a ser igual a 5 si no tiene este dato
no lo va a poder resolver 6 al 1 bueno
aquí no le hace falta cuatro menos
cuatro igual a cero bueno tampoco que le
hizo falta y seis menos cuatro igualados
pues tampoco aplica aquí así que nuestra
respuesta es la opción a veamos otro
problema que eso están bastante
sencillos muy bien cuál es el valor del
logaritmo base 3 de 27 aquí lo que nos
preguntan es 3 a la x igual a 27
pues cuál va a ser esta x veamos tres en
uno es 33 al cuadrado es
93 al cubo es 27 así que tres al cubo
es igual a 27 por lo que este logaritmo
es nuestra opción b
no estoy notando que va aumentando el
grado de dificultad en estos problemas
vemos el siguiente
es aproximadamente punto 301 y el
logaritmo de 13 aproximadamente punto
477 cuál es el valor aproximado del
organismo de 72 bueno cuando las
personas se escriben los logaritmos sin
usar una base normalmente se asume que
es base 10 así está en su calculadora el
botón que dice el ojo es logaritmo base
10 aquí tengo que hacer una
factorización tengo mi logaritmo
de 72
72 es nueve veces ocho así que el
logaritmo de 72 es igual al logaritmo
de 9 x 8
que esto es lo mismo que el logaritmo
de 9 más el logaritmo de 8
es lo mismo que el logaritmo
logaritmo de 3 al cuadrado más el
logaritmo de 2 al cubo estoy tratando de
dejar todo en términos de logaritmo 2 y
logaritmo 3 ok esto así en esta forma es
igualados por el logaritmo de tres más
tres por el logaritmo de 2
y ahora sustituyó el logaritmo de 2 y el
logaritmo de 3 me va a quedar 2 por el
logaritmo de
30.4 77 más 3 por el logaritmo de 20
puntos
301 hacemos la multiplicación 2 por
punto
aquí voy a tener que hacer una operación
a un ladito
477 x 2 es igual 7 por 2 14 7 por los 14
llevamos una 15
4 por 2 8 y una 9 954 ok
es por uno cuando éste es punto 3 por 1
3 3 por 0 0 3 por 3
9.903 así que apunto
953 sumamos 903
1.903 nos va a quedar 7 5
con punto así que es nuestra opción de
estar acá
1.857
veamos el siguiente problema si x es un
número real para cuales valores de x la
ecuación 3x menos 9 entre 3 igual a x
menos 3 es verdadera vamos a escribirla
nos preguntan 3 x menos 9 entre 3 para
que valores de x
esta ecuación es verdadera
ok vamos a multiplicar por 3 ambos lados
de la ecuación me va a quedar 3 por esto
esto por 3
esto se va me queda 3x menos 9 igual a 3
por x 3 x menos 3 x 3 9 y bueno aquí nos
detenemos si tenemos algo y lo
multiplicamos por 3 y a eso le restamos
9 pues va a ser igual a ese algo
multiplicado por tres
restándole 9 así que esto siempre se va
a cumplir es más vamos a sumar 9 en
ambos lados de la ecuación me queda 3x
igual a 3 x
dividimos ambos lados entre 3 esto entre
3 es 33 y me queda que x es igual a
equis y esto pues siempre se va a
cumplir así que es la opción a todos los
valores de x veamos el último problema
en un examen arturo escribió la ecuación
x cuadrada menos 16 entre x menos 4 es
igual a x + 4 cuando los siguientes
enunciados es correcto acerca de las
ecuaciones que escribió con ustedes ven
algo así como esta x cuadrada menos 16
/
x4 igual a x4 tienen que factorizar y
simplificar esto de acá es lo mismo voy
a escribir bien el 4 que escribir x 4
por x 4
/ x 4
y esto es igual a x4 lo cual es cierto
ya que esto de aquí se va con esto de
acá me queda esto con esto eso está bien
asumiendo que el número del denominador
es diferente de cero para que sea cero
aquí x tiene que ser igual a 4 así que
se cumple esto excepto para cuando x es
igual a 4 así que va a ser nuestra
opción b la ecuación siempre es verdad
el excepto para x igual a 4 si yo fuera
a graficar esta ecuación x cuadrada
menos 16 entre x menos 4 sería la misma
gráfica que la de x + 4 excepto que para
x igual a 4 habría un hueco en ese punto
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo